and um have you made a decision uh today
whether you intend to testify or whether
you intend to invoke your fifth
amendment privilege
uh i will invoke my fifth amendment
privilege today
mr showman i'm going to address you
directly uh uh
because the
decision whether or not to testify
is entirely yours in other words it's a
personal right
mr nelson makes a lot of the decisions
in trial
but one he cannot make for you is
whether or not you testify
and he can give you advice and you can
take that advice or reject that advice
but the decision ultimately has to be
yours and not his
is this your decision not to testify it
does your honor
all right do you have any questions
about your right to remain silent or to
testify on your own behalf
not at this time i don't all right does
anyone uh
promise anything or threaten you in any
way to keep you from testifying
no promises or threats your honor do you
feel that your decision not to testify
is a voluntary one on your behalf
yes it is now in addition to that i'm
convinced uh then that this is your
personal decision
uh and that you're aware of your rights
but there is a jury instruction
that may be read to the jury this again
is the one that you
get to weigh in on it's not for your
lawyer to make the decision again he can
give you advice and i don't you
don't want to know what the advice is
but you can accept the advice or reject
the advice
as to whether or not to give this
instruction if you would like
i can read this instruction to the jury
it's titled defendant's right not to
testify the state must convince you by
evidence beyond a reasonable doubt
that the defendant is guilty of the
crime charged the defendant has no
obligation to pro
to prove innocence the defendant has the
right not to testify
this right is guaranteed by the federal
and state constitutions
you should not draw any inference from
the fact that the defendant has not
testified in this case
do you understand that instruction yes
your honor would you like that read to
the jury
yes your honor have you had enough time
to talk to mr nelson about whether
that's a good idea or not
i have your honor all right and so i
will read that to the jury on your
request
thank you all right anything else
regarding the defense case before we
proceed to talk about rebuttal
all right uh we'll have you rest in
front of the jury then
and we could actually take the
microphone back ms boss thank you
thank you we'll have you arrested in
front of the jury
mr nelson
okay so derek chovin there being
questioned by
his defense lawyer and telling the court
that he has chosen to invoke the fifth
amendment
he will not testify before the court
let's return to greg milam who's
outside the court in minneapolis for us
largely expected that he wouldn't be
giving testimony greg
yeah well as i was saying before we we
heard from derek shoving we hadn't
actually heard his voice in court at all
other than some body camera recordings
from from the day in may last year
it's it's quite usual in a trial here in
the u.s for the judge to ask a defendant
those questions whether he's he's doing
this voluntarily deciding not to testify
and and we heard that derek shovings
saying that it was purely voluntary he'd
not been promised anything
not been threatened it was his decision
uh not to testify in his defense
and you heard there what the jury will
be told they're not in court at the
moment what they will be told about that
that they can't infer anything from the
fact that he has chosen not to testify
and and
with that that conversation with his
lawyer eric nelson there
saying that he's choosing to to invoke
the fifth amendment or he would if he
was asked questions
uh that of course the the right not to
incriminate yourself um under the u.s
constitution
uh other witnesses uh potential
witnesses have done that in this trial
so we now know we won't hear from derek
chovin
in his defense uh in this trial uh we
expect that the the defense case will
end today they may have one other
uh witness uh the expectation is that on
monday the the prosecution and defense
will begin
to deliver their their closing arguments
in this case